se han dado cuenta que cada primero
enero la gente se pone propósito se han
fijado que no podemos comenzar a hacer
una dieta a empezar curso si no el lunes
qué curioso como a lo largo de nuestra
vida
creemos que los propósitos se ponen el
lunes o en primero de enero nos cueste
empezar un nuevo reto un jueves y pues
no sé colcha vamos y encima somos
esperan los tres días más a que sea
lunes
soy Carmen cálzate yo les vengo a
practicar mis cuatro acuerdos
tengo la oportunidad de ser presidente
del Consejo de Participación Ciudadana
de la Secretaría de Desarrollo Social
del Estado de Nuevo León Secretaría
tiene un consejo ciudadano
qué vigila las aportaciones que hace el
gobierno en diferentes temas temas de
pobreza de reducción de desigualdad de
mujeres víctimas de violencia de
adicciones de centros comunitarios y a
lo largo de estos 6 años hace cinco
exactamente una buena y querida amiga me
dio la oportunidad y la dicha de asistir
a un centro penitenciario
cuando yo llegue al centro penitenciario
y conocí la vida de todas las personas
que estaban allá dentro me di cuenta que
ellos no eran victimarios que no
solamente eran agresores eran víctimas
víctimas de una sociedad que no les
hemos dado oportunidades
que no tuviera nada mejor una familia
unida
cercanos a las adicciones a las drogas a
la pobreza a las igualdad que no
tuvieron una educación de calidad
me senté con ellos no se escuche
practique sus historias me di cuenta
como sufrían cómo se sentían amarrados
como no se sentían libres
tiempo después me invitan a ser madrina
de generación de la generación 52 al
interior del centro penitenciario aunque
puede parecer
contradictorio hay un centro de
rehabilitación de adicciones y en este
centro de adicciones las personas que de
manera voluntaria o previamente ser
liberados pasan 100 días en este centro
un centro en donde los acompañas donde
les ayudan a desintoxicar sé y me
inviten como madrina de generación
empecé a ir durante esos 100 días semana
esta semana visitarlos a conocer sus
historias a escuchar sus angustias y
pues llegue el día de la graduación y
micen Carmen queremos que tú seas de
madrina
te puedes imaginar lo que yo sentí que
me iba parar enfrente a decirles que ha
compartido es que hombre sin esperanza
sin ilusión sin libertad
creo mucho las diosidencias y saliendo
de ahí me encuentro una amiga muy
querida y me plática una frase de San
Agustín que dice florece donde la vida
te plante y cuando yo escuché esa frase
dije esa es la frase que tengo que
compartir el día de hoy con todas estas
personas privadas de su libertad y que
hoy quiero compartirles ustedes también
como mi primer acuerdo
florece donde la vida te plante durante
esos 100 días con los historias de
sueños frustrados
de personas que querían ser músicos
querían ser artistas que era ser
pintores que inclusive trabajar en la
Iglesia
lecciones de hacer capturas de esos días
con diferentes donaciones
pues atriles de fuimos acercando brochas
acuarelas guitarras
pelotas de diferentes deportes y se les
fue dando la oportunidad de que ellos
descubrieran como querían florecer y
darse cuenta que aún al interior de un
centro penitenciario
puedes florecer donde la vida te planto
y cambiaron esas historias historias
donde empezaron hacer torneos deportivos
dónde empezaron hacer exposiciones de
arte
juntamos libros para hacer una
biblioteca y empezaron a hacerse
círculos de lectura
una semana después de esa graduación
caminando yo por el centro penitenciario
me di cuenta que con uno de esos
muchachos que le haya tocado ese mensaje
había valido la pena florece donde la
vida te plante este hermoso mural que me
encontré al interior
a ver esas vidas transformadas esos
sueños cambiados cuántas veces tú que
estás escuchando esto el día de hoy te
sientes encerrada a pesar de estar libre
y ellos a pesar de estar encerrados se
sienten muy libres la invitación hoy con
este primer acuerdo está nos cuenta
donde estamos plantados donde estamos
sembrados en la riqueza y en la pobreza
con la familia funcional o aquella que
no lo es con muchos amigos o con pocos
en México o en el extranjero
florece donde la vida te plante
tengo la oportunidad del 2005 de ser
directora Fundación frisa Fundación
prisa es la fundación de esta empresa
familiar en donde tenemos oportunidad de
compartir las tres tes
tres peces que tengo que yo llevar a los
cerca de 1800 colaboradores para que
ellos vivan tiempo
talento
y tesoro
tiempo como vives tu tiempo como
inviertes tu tiempo no les pasa que
ellos que tienen ese donde le dice eso
semana aumentaste a 4 horas de estar en
redes sociales
cómo inviertes tu tiempo
acompañando un adulto mayor
con tiempo de ocio de recreación lo
inviertes bien
lo que ya pasó ayer no va a volver a
pasar lo que pasó hace una hora no va a
volver a pasar
análisis en durante este top cómo
invierten su tiempo
dónde pasan la mayor parte de su tiempo
en cosas que le han placer que les dan
valor que generan algo en la comunidad
que generan algo para usted mismo y no
para cumplir las expectativas de los
demás pero si para cumplir las
expectativas propias es la primer T
talento
talento cada uno somos únicos
irrepetibles
cada uno con nuestros talentos y
peculiaridades
ese talento que tenemos para compartir
eres buena para manejar redes sociales
será que puedes aportar tu talento y tu
tiempo en organización de discapacidad
para mover las redes sociales
será que eres buenísimo para la
contabilidad y hay alguna universidad
que requiere que alguien una unidad
pequeña que requiere que alguien es
verdad sus temas contable
eres increíble para las artes y será que
hay un orfanatorio que se pudiera
beneficiar de tu talento para irse a
compartir con esos niños
talento
ya es cubriste tu talento y si ya lo
descubriste como lo puedes compartir
y la tercer te-100 portalento y tesoro
tesoro aquello que duele no lo que nos
sobra por algo existe el yerno cuánto
estás cuánto das y de qué manera lo das
lo das esperando recibir un retorno
social sobre esa inversión
ciudad esperando que hay un mundo mejor
después de que lo das que haya menos
pobreza menos desigualdad menos
violencia
o lo das simplemente porque el mar tu
corazón
tesoro se habla de que hay millones de
pesos que sean en México y vemos un
México igual porque vemos un México
igual pues porque no hemos sabido
compartir bien ese tesoro con Marian
inteligente de una manera estratégica
tiempo talento y tesoros
a lo largo de 1017 años de carrera
profesional tanto en Fundación frisa
como Fundación comunidad y como el
gobierno el Estado
pues hoy esposa soy madre soy amiga su
hija
soy ciudadana
hace 3 años les confieso que tuve un pez
da un tremendo un agotamiento físico y
mental ya no sabía qué hacer y me tope
con esta frase que me repito todas y
cada una de las mañanas y para quiénes
se sienten a veces como yo abrumados por
tantas actividades
los invito a repetirse las cajas mañana
yo me dijo Carmen elegir es renunciar
si yo esta mañana
elegí hacer ejercicio sea que renuncie
una hora más de sueño
si yo esta tarde elijo una tarde con
amigas me doy cuenta que renuncio a
dormir más temprano
cada lección tiene una renuncia yo no
puedo elegir elegir elegir elegir elegir
porque el día tiene 24 horas
nada más y la semana tiene solamente 7
días aquel hijo ya que renuncio yo lo
puedo comprar un poquito como este este
subibaja no y me encanta pensar que toda
elección tiene una renuncia y compararla
con el tema de balance versus
balancearte a mí no me gusta cuando me
dicen es que tienes que buscar el
balance el balance perfecto no existe
pero si existe el balancearte si existe
ese ir y venir en dónde se do Boi
en dónde estoy continuamente
balanceandome entonces me cargó si a la
familia y luego si el trabajo y luego si
a los amigos y luego si a mí misma y
luego es el deporte y luego es el ocio
es estarme balanceando
yo me imagino
pues así no entre dos cataratas si hay
bajas en la cuerda floja y cómo vas
viendo en esos circos como están en ese
continuo balance balance balance
buscando cómo balancear nos llevamos
tres acuerdos florece donde la vida te
plante
las tres tes tiempo talento y tesoro y
elegidos renunciar
hasta ahorita como se van sintiendo en
esos acuerdos
por qué es importante darnos cuenta que
no todos empiezan primero de enero no
todos empieza un lunes y no todo tiene
que ser de calor cuántos tienes tú 234
125 empiezas en octubre en un sábado
y el cuarto acuerdo me encanta me
encanta pensar en este en este acuerdo
que me digo a mí misma
este acuerdo lo escuché en una
conferencia de una escritor de un autor
que se llama Tal Ben-Shahar tal Ben
Shahar el maestro no es de Harvard y
tienes que libro precioso que se llama
happy
y dentro de este libro y ya le ha dicho
a ir leyendo me tope con una frase que
realmente dije esa quiero ser esa quiero
ser y dice no te preguntes que necesita
el mundo
pregúntate que te hace vibrar porque lo
que el mundo necesita es gente viva y
gente que vibre
hace varios años de invitaron
aceleradoras de la Universidad de
Monterrey del Tec de Monterrey en las
grabaciones
Escocia eso que yo no me acuerdo quién
fue orador huésped ni nadie los que
están aquí se acuerdan yo me imagino y
dije bueno dado que nadie se va a
acordar de mí sí quiero que se acuerden
de algo
yo le dije no te preguntes que necesita
el mundo pregúntate que te hace vibrar
porque lo que realmente el mundo
necesita es gente viva y gente que vibre
no pretendemos hacer cosas que
extraordinarias hagamos de lo ordinario
algo extraordinario
no busquemos cambiar tono volvieron pues
queremos cambiar nuestro m2
porque la medida que cambiamos nuestro
m2 cuando se topa con el tuyo y con el
tuyo y con el tuyo y con el tuyo
logramos llegar a cambiar un gran km2
eso es lo que tenemos que hacer ver que
nos hace vibrar la danza las artes la
escritura Eldad el servir los números
que te hace vibrar y ve y acceso
si todos realmente hiciéramos lo que nos
hace vibrar el mundo sería distinto
creo que lo largo de mi vida me he dado
cuenta que esos acuerdos funcionan más
que ser propósitos los invito el día hoy
a preguntarse
y dónde están plantados ustedes han
florecido y este florecimiento requiere
riego requiere que se fertilizan
requiere poda no es una planta perfecta
y estos tristes tu tiempo tu talento tu
tesoro como lo das a partir de hoy no
como lo has venido haciendo eso ya no
importa como quieres darlo y agarra un
libro y escribe cómo quieres dar cada
uno de estos tres texto tiempo tu
talento y tú tesoro
aprende que elegir es renunciar
que yo no puedo solamente elegir porque
el mundo el tiempo las horas la semana
es finito y pregúntate que te hace
vibrar porque lo que el mundo necesita
es gente viva y gente que vibre soy
Carmen alsatel y me encantó estar aquí
con ustedes